hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the digital the
digitalization of the vivarium past and
present initiatives that optimize animal
care and welfare presented by John Jay
has now she is a principal and a lab
animal consultant at the laboratory
animal community
I am Marjorie Torres the blabbers and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
Lavery lab booth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
will move on during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of your screen
or use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the accreditation button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming John
Jay Haas now I will now turn the
presentation over to him all right good
morning afternoon evening or wherever
you are to all on the webinar and I
appreciate the invitation to be here and
hopefully we'll present some things that
are interesting and exciting to you as
they are to me I'm talking today about
digitalization of the by barium past and
present and just to show you what will
be going through today here's the
overview we have different animal room
monitoring systems and then rack and
blower units and obviously spending a
lot of time on cages
that's might been my passion for many
years and still is and I think it's an
interesting time
for the lab animal community in regards
to opportunities of how things are
progressing
technically in that area at this current
point in time and then we need to talk a
little bit about infrastructure needs
and then operational efficiencies and
potential returns on investments in
relationship to what we are talking
about in relative unimpaired communal
efficiencies in benefits meaning working
with EP eyes in some of the ways that
some of these caging systems can help in
other areas of the vivarium rather than
just the animals alone so I'll do a
summary in questions at the end as well
so to start off what I'd like to do is
talk about some establish and well-known
systems such as the Siemens
bas integrated system or Apogee and then
go into ed strim watchdog and then ear
acuity and these were picked because
these are ones that I've worked with in
the past and know fairly well but it
also is an evolutionary type of approach
here in regards to our digitalization
and how they're working within the
building automated systems and it's also
a way of showing the technology involved
with this overall these are fully
interactive with the BAS the initial
focus was always on animal welfare
components the alarming and ability to
notify these are still very crucial
components throughout all these systems
and then there have been improved
interactive abilities and remote
capabilities as we've gone on air
conditioning and control tends to be one
of our huge resource resource
consumptions for the animal facilities
and one where we have a lot of cost in
regards overall to this it represents a
major ROI for institutions with rapid
short-term returns if it can be managed
appropriately so excuse me just showing
some of the examples here of an Apogee
system and that's kind of a building
based system with that and excuse me
again and then Siemens
within their units have developed on to
Italian system which is more of a common
university multi building type system to
go ahead and
manage these and then look at air flows
and needs with that in essence we're
starting to look at more smart building
type of situations here with many
different sensors an ability to go ahead
and troll the flows on more of a need
basis especially with some of the
ducting systems in relationship to our
air flows for hoods in other areas
within the biological confinement or
containment facilities overall when we
start looking at the Eckstrom system and
that was predominantly based on more of
a security basis and looking at room
control and ability to enter the rooms
and then go ahead and monitor who's in
the rooms as well as frequency of going
into the room security of the room
itself and then adding in the water flow
consumer concerns and abilities to
monitor that and to keep those systems
monitored and digitalized as well there
is more evolution with this they're
working to integrate more into other
systems with this system but essentially
it's a standalone system at this point
in time for them but I think they are
moving toward working more in other
relationships with this at this area of
time
this is still a very good system it
allows leak control and other issues to
be monitored overall those are working
concerns for us we're starting to look
at more air quality issues and really
when we start looking at that air acuity
comes into play and the air qualities
that we're looking at are based on three
or four different basis or three or four
different areas that we're looking at
co2 temperature humidity of course which
has always been one of the issues but
also TB OCS and being able to monitor
the VOCs overall in being able to go
ahead and accommodate air flows and
relationship to that what I've noticed a
lot in a lot of the primate facilities
that I've consulted or worked with is
where they are actually able to look at
particulate and particulate is a big
issue for us
and then monitoring or ramping up when
there are high particulate times and
decreasing air flows when there's
decrease particulate times this is
essentially tied into wash downs and
ability to monitor around those and be
able to monitor the air flows around
those and anticipate some of those at a
time so ramping up just before wash
downs and then waiting and tell those
particulate matter dropping up and then
coming back down to where it is within
control also with different stocking
densities you will get different co2
levels they are very good at monitoring
that and looking at the air flow needs
through that and everything that is
related with that as I mentioned air
quality is becoming more of a challenge
across all of the world globally we
still have designated flows in Canada
and England there on engineering
standards still but an understanding
that that may move in the near future
here especially with Canada starting one
possibly follow holding rooms are at
about six to ten the average is eight in
terms of room ik for air exchanges per
hour and this is based on the RAC
exhaust rate and thermal loads labs tend
to be in about two to four the average
of three exchanges per hour
air quality TB OCS ammonia co2 and
particulates are the four areas that are
really heavily monitored here and demand
control ventilation is then allowed the
monitoring is about every 15 minutes
with established parameters and your
response times you need to be able to
respond to changes in that but you don't
want to respond too rapidly because
otherwise you'll never have a baseline
so usually there's a five to ten minute
baseline response time and then
reconfiguration before it is responding
to in that sense with that so this kind
of gets us on to the BAS itself and
development and really what we're seeing
now is with smart buildings there's
three emerging technology trends in
building automation and cloud computing
is one of them machine learning and
artificial intelligence
connectivity and intraday ssin or the
Internet of Things and that's really
what we're starting to talk about with
some of the airflows and some of the
different particulate matter or sensing
co2 sensing that we're seeing in some of
the space areas for the lab animals so
this is building into a concept the
Internet of Things that is coming very
rapidly into our areas of technology and
we need to understand this and hopefully
help with this overall as another
example I wanted to go into the rack
blower unit digitalization in the
circuit of 1990 IBC's with their
introduction then there was a lab animal
welfare emphasis in airflow dominantly
in the alarm and notification focus with
these blower units neat room versus
individual rack individual rack and
assurance a backup power the supply
units as well was another critical
component for the animal welfare and and
with these we also saw a little better
ventilation control per rack on these
with then in the rooms overall rooms
were very hard to control with
everything with that so with individual
IBC's the racks tend to be the primary
control basis for H fax and then what
we're seeing is where we can either duck
down into the primary system or use
these individual blower units and use
them to ventilate this at the cajon that
way so Sarah about 2014 temperature
humidity monitoring emphasis on
individual racks and remote monitoring
that was something that there were
humidity additions available they needed
water supplied to the units so that was
important as well in terms of any of the
design function for facilities in circa
about 2016 here we started to see
individual health monitoring cataract
level this is not digital but it's
manual and this is something that could
be digitalized in the future possibly
we'll talk about that a little bit I
wanted to just show some pictures of
different rack and blower unit
digitalization is here so again
going into main lines this way for the
building facility systems and pulling
the exhaust air out with that or going
ahead and I'm bringing the exhaust air
into the room via some of the blower
units so there are many different
configurations of this and ways to do
this
the better ways in some of these
situations based on noise and vibration
is tending to look at standalone blower
units and wandering or working with that
or working with the building system
itself or you can look into that so
these are things that we need to think
about when we're designing facilities
and working toward developing the best
rack system and an air quality to the
animals with that the blower unit
digitalisation x' you can see here that
we have the Wi-Fi unit setups and these
again were are very popular and are have
the ability to individually set
different flow rates for different racks
and alarms for different racks and the
ability to correct those remotely as
well in relationship to the
digitalization of these and ility to use
Wi-Fi components with this overall with
the humidity and temperature again these
are getting more advanced as we progress
and in the Nordic areas areas of high
altitude these are very critical and
important a lot of times our building
systems can't keep up with the need for
the rack in regards to individual cages
especially so these systems are becoming
more popular and you're starting to see
these more prevalent throughout the
community these can be either locally or
centrally controlled and looking at
remote now with some of these as well in
relationship to the digitalization in
with a focus on animal welfare with this
and the other area that I mentioned
earlier was the health monitoring on the
racks so we're seeing a lot of the EAD
now being used for the exhaust air dust
these systems are built into the plenums
and then have filters that are detecting
what is going on with that exhaust air
dust or collecting that exhaust air dust
is what I should properly say here and
there isn't technology at this point in
time where it can automatically say that
there are problems or anything along
those lines but there is other
technology out there that is being
looked at by several folks and several
companies to evaluate the possibilities
of having automated systems for this in
the future so this is something else
that is exciting and possibly coming
down line in the future in relationship
to this we're seeing some of this also
with the possibility of looking at this
in regards to the zebra fish tank setups
as well and monitoring them and looking
at automation of that in regards to some
of the results we might get from that so
what I really want to spend time on is
cage typically digitalization and when
we start talking about cage
digitalization I'm really talking about
automated homepage monitoring and
technology evolution here really if we
want to say what is the first way that
we monitor cages or animals continuously
24/7 I think we would have to agree that
telemetry was the basis of that and
starting early beginnings where we could
go ahead and monitor the physiological
aspects of an animal point four seven
via Twitter tree and still do in many
cases what we did see is with this early
evolution there were problems with
battery systems implanting these and
others and this is evolved now to where
some of these units are battery lists
they work off charging systems
underneath the cages themselves and can
be implanted in animals that way so
there's been quite a lot of
digitalization for the animals and for
the caging in regards to that and some
of that is EMF based related to those
charging systems there's better and more
advanced progress with behavioral
studies and then doing video
analytics and this was a neural science
drive with this with some of the
behavioral components and then
developing algorithm programs based off
of the video diagnosis and looking at
what type of behavior or aspects that
are occurring with these animals with
that this is primarily study focused and
and what we were seeing is then with
this the ability for some of the
algorithms to be quite sophisticated and
be able to tell us what type of specific
type of behaviors the animals are having
most recently we started seeing the
electronic magnetic fields the low
electronic magnetic field development
and usage for management and study use
the advantage of EMF or el EMF is that
and it allows both management of the
cage and study evaluations as well so it
has a kind of a dual focus that way and
I'm going to spend a fair amount of time
talking about the EMF abilities with the
technology and how that works and also
comparing that to some of the other
video systems and other ways of doing
behavioral analysis with that animal
welfare focus predominantly with these
automated home caged systems the
continuous nature of those allows 24/7
evaluation for animal movements and then
also in some cases a cage environment
emphasis on better study conductance
continuous study data in the homepage so
you're not having to move animals out
disrupting those animals and causing
complications in regards to and the
stress that the animals might have or
the non acclamation of this different
study apparatus in - and and more
recently we've been seeing EMF cage
management with this in terms of the
ability to actually determine when cage
changes or cage change out cycles should
be determined so we'll evaluate that
look at that as well here in this
presentation there's opportunities and
all of this for great
or savings labor and consumables as well
as the ability to have better
reproducibility of data on data cheering
overall some of the home page monitoring
systems are mentioned here and looking
at the technology we can see that a lot
of it is video based and RFID chips you
can individually identify animals in
that but also there are being braking
vibration systems there is also some gas
monitoring for metabolic needs that way
too with some of these systems and the
very last one down there with the
technology is a map and you know get
into that more but this is a a caging
system that are a technology that's
fairly new in regards to being used in
this manner and it's been Eurocentric
predominantly but it's really coming
over to North America now we're seeing
this more more now here in North America
so one of these looks like here are some
of the cages there are some with the
video RF IDs as you can see in the upper
left hand corner there the beam break
vibration is kind of in the middle there
another video ahran on RFID but just
video system here is on the upper right
and if we look at some of the metabolic
cages here like this one in the lower
left hand corner you can see here that
really there's some changes in regards
to the actual holding cage from what you
would expect for being a normal cage the
one thing about the EMF system is this
allows a normal cage being placed into
its holding environment and then the
environment measures the activity and
measures the animal much the same as
these video systems are doing here and
here where the home cages are the home
page itself what we would describe as a
lone page but we're not altering the
tops nor are we altering the cage itself
and then letting the animal live in
there applet for three or four weeks
they are the cage it's already a
climatic and this is a great time
savings and the facilities in regards to
acclamation periods and stabilization
it's boarding animals overall so I just
wanted to clear that up and make sure
people had a good understanding of that
because there is a lot of variety in
what is defined as a home cage system at
this point time the cage digitalisation
itself if we're looking at that you can
actually monitor animals for behavior
and welfare components and then and the
environment welfare management again
with some of the caging systems like
using the EMF systems for that it allows
Kate cage inventory management and
resource allocations as well adds to and
enhances automation support of the
internet-of-things overall we're working
with those so really for 50-plus years
the mouse cage has been a box and we
haven't done a lot with that box what if
you can provide information to the user
like the bedding conditioned cage change
scheduling animal activity or lack of
activity and what if the cages were
really based on need criteria rather
than calendar and I think this is an
important concept here we're really
starting to see more and more of this in
vivarium now where people are looking at
criteria rather than calendar for years
we've used calendars and there's been
huge wastes in regards to the calendar
based systems and the ability to manage
those systems well in regards to the
resources so what is considered dirty
cage is is is a dirty cage reproducible
in regards to different facilities and
again each facility will have its own
definition the ability to go ahead and
say what a dirty cage is is something
that you know the system should be able
to do can we reduce the risk of the
animal allergy exposures and how can we
reduce that risk overall by lack of
changing cages too often or having
animals exposed too often overall from
moving the animals from one page to
another or into study experimental areas
with that a researcher doesn't have to
worry that his or her mice were being
stressed by K changes and could collect
data in a home page would be something
that would be very optimal as well
research and management can accurately
tell when each cage change
to enhance study management and study
correlations overall so this is
important I think to for everyone
involved in trkage monitoring the Betty
convincing modules could kind of
increase efficiency by changing washing
based on a need and we'll get into a
specific study that I'll show you that
and what that actually means in terms of
a decreased amount of K changing and
combining inter cage monitoring with
complete page change combined benefits
overall same technology that monitors
the bedding can collect other data the
systems are quite varied that way we
look at activity presence of food water
and this is being shown here in regards
to how some of the food water can be
evaluated in these systems with the
infrared beam technology and then
indications when those are issues of a
alert overall with a red light indicator
the other thing I'd like to point out is
that not only does it measure that if
there's a water bottle presence but the
actual correct positioning of a water
bottle not put in an upside down and the
level of water within the water bottle
as well these are all management
concerns that we've had in many
different facilities and this is
something that can give great relief
when you're having a system that will
allow some of that to be measured so
some of the questions that may come from
our facility managers that I remember to
put that water bottle back on what I
just explained are we going to have time
to prepare for a lack is there
absolutely no way I'm going to have time
enough time today to do senses so what
am I going to do with Brian called out
sink these gauges new really need to be
changed today his work distributed
evenly throughout the staff did Bob
really change all those gauges today
when is this mouse going to have her
pumps great question when it where is
dr. winters cage of importance we've
never had that question right anybody
are we wasting food or bedding and how
much food bedding do I need to order how
many cages do I have right now Oh
as this mouse been dead is this mouse
acting crazy or is it me am I going to
have to justify more staffing or how can
I justify even more staffing this this
guy ever going to stop asking questions
so I hope I didn't cause any anxiety in
folks with all of these mentioned
questions here but again these are
common questions a lot of the things
that we do within the facilities can be
answered through some of the
technologies that we have available to
us one of the things that we need to
start thinking about is how to let it go
in terms of worrying too much and
there's a great book out there called
getting things done the art of
stress-free productivity I would
recommend it as a read to all who are
listening and a lot of times what we
want to do is you know we kind of
register problems in our minds and we
always think about those problems but we
know it's not a big problem but you know
we're not going to go ahead and spend a
lot of time on it but we actually do we
kind of keep coming back to that and
everything that way so if there's one
thing we can do the happiest people are
those who can do it with the limit of
their ability and we can be completely
present we can be all there we just need
to let it go and we need to give all our
attention to the opportunity before us
now I'm worried about those other little
things they can be handled other ways
and we really need to focus on letting
it go and we can rely on technology one
of the things that our community is not
real good at is going ahead and moving
forward with technology in a rapid
fashion or in an acceptable fashion in a
lot of ways
so really the advantages of the
technology is the security the
consistency the efficiency and then the
options that hitl it allows us to go
ahead and really pick through ways that
we want to manage and we can best manage
with what resources we have so having
that in mind there's some ways that we
can go ahead and look at cage to do
civilization
and looking at the real thing here is
the concept of the Internet of Things I
don't know how many folks have heard of
this term before but it's really coming
on and it's really interconnectivity of
processes and ability to plan and
allocate resources efficiently and
effectively and there's a lot of
interplay here than with smart
technology and relationship to this in
the Internet of Things in being able to
do a lot of analytics and being able to
interplay with those analytics and look
at the best path forward and a lot of
conditions with the Internet
introduction of the Internet of animals
I wanted to talk a little bit about a
paper that had come out in 2016 animal
research the three hours and the
Internet of Things opportunities nobre
site international pharmaceutical
development Steve named Ian Dale Davies
were the authors of this wonderful
article and it really talked about
standardizations of global data
collections and analytics and increased
sharing but it also alluded a lot to the
ability to improve welfare and care and
better understanding through regional
effects of environmental variables and
remote live area monitoring as well
allowing us better reactivity and
collaborations then in looking at how
those different areas are one of the big
things we are seeing is a lot of issues
with reproducibility reproducibility is
a concern at several levels but
understanding where the concerns are is
difficult at times
and these systems are very helpful in
understanding how some of those concerns
are developed and where they really are
so and we can sustain and support
research utility husbandry veterinary
care ethics is framed by the 3 R's for
use of a lot of this technology that's
out there with that with the in with the
Internet of Things we also can talk
about the Internet of animals which was
introduced back in
2016 as well and this was a interesting
concept and that we're talking about
wearables are genetically engineered
animals geotag monitor net are connected
where we can monitor some of the field
studies of how ecology is changing and
then the massive movements of wild
animals and then also go back into owner
and veterinary communications and look
at those type of inter reactions there
so it really gets down to how granular
can we go can we go to the Internet of
the librarian can we start looking at
how we interplay within the vivarium and
how changing one thing affects several
others down the line and how this
affects things globally as well with
those Internet's with the Internet of
the vivarium and the ability for some of
the global data analysis and work that
way so and if we talk about the Internet
of the vivarium one of the things that I
wanted to propose was looking at the
very basics and very baby steps and
starting with K change-out management
and how would that work we can start
looking at dirty caging itself
identified then caged out units and
inventory identified resources for those
cages helps identify initiation with a
personal resource management system to
go ahead and allow personnel there for
the K change outs and then schedule of
the gage unit delivery change out and
then delivery to cage watch schedule or
so in speaking of baby steps what I want
to do is take us to a facility that is
in Prague Czechoslovakia and and talk
about what they have done at this
particular facility which is the
Institute of molecular genetics this is
a facility that has had a lot of
background in regards to going ahead and
developing their their supply of mice to
all of Europe and they're a breeder
facility they have a lot of transgenics
there they also run a mutant colony
there and they're also a phenotype core
so they're very
they are a center of excellence with
this but they were running out of space
and in addition to running out of space
they were running into some issues of
not having a barrier in their
experimental facility which then caused
some contamination issues so long story
short they've built a new facility that
new facility and I'm sorry here's the
indications for their Eurocentric supply
for my statway and the new facility is
actually in best tech which is about
nine miles south of Prague this facility
is called bio C bio Sivas several
different institutions that have gotten
together that have supported this it's a
four and a four for animal facility new
as of 2016 there are still building and
developing in the facility it is both a
barrier breeding facility in a barrier
experimental facility and they have a
very good quarantine their capacity of
this facility is about 13,000 cages of
mice and about 3,400 cages of rats so
looking at this facility we've got
several different areas of it this is
one of the mouse areas here outlined in
red this is another I'm sorry this is a
rat area outlined in red here and then
this area is actually a DBC strictly
using the DPC caging the EMF caging by
in this area here this little area is a
test area for looking at the caging it's
outside of the barre area this whole
area is the barrier breeding facility on
the bottom floor of this facility their
cage wash is actually two floors up and
they the gate 30 cages from that area on
up into the main cage wash area from
there so looking at this I want to then
dive into how the DBC cage itself works
and and the DBC cage is based upon a
developing and electromagnetic field and
then measuring that electromagnetic
field this is an extremely low very tiny
electromagnetic
feel that is much less than what we are
exposed to on a daily basis overall it's
done by having a current go through a
electrical plate and then you develop a
basic electromagnetic field from that
there are 12 sensory primary sensory and
receivers here and in the in the
electric plate these electric plates are
underneath each holding cage in the rack
so the rack is of normal size and
dimension and density and the cages then
sit on top of these electromagnetic
place if you will electric plates and
the e.l.f which is impacted by
dielectric materials like mice will then
you have a different signal coming back
from the animals that way when they're
in the presence of one of those
proprietary sensors there's 24/7
continuous welfare checking and auto
phenotyping in regards to this so
realistically in showing you more
diagrammatically here what will happen
with the signals and when you have an
mpk cage with 30 bedding presence of an
animal animal moving away in cage with
white bedding now I think one thing that
can be confusing is that these areas
here both the animal movement and the
cage evaluation the substrate evaluation
is done simultaneously through
algorithms so the system allows
simultaneous algorithm interpretation of
both animal movement and of the cage
condition very important in terms of the
management as well as the activity of
the animals overall so going back into
the biopsy facility and their specific
area with the DVC system or the EMF
system what was done first was a
learning phase so 20 cages with two
animals then 20 cages with three animals
20 cages with for animals and 20 cages
with five animals
this declared what a dirty cage was for
the system based on density based on
these densities overall so each
individual facility is going to have
their own SOP for how dirty a cage is
and this system will allow you to have
that diversity in regards to what a
dirty cage is so you can go ahead and
direct the system and the system learns
as well as its go in progress as to what
your de cages are our world with this
after that had been done the first phase
was running for 89 days without using
the DBC turned on this was the calendar
based system and giving an idea of how
many cages were actually changed in that
period with the amount of cages in the
area the other next phase that was done
was with the DBC on and then this was
going ahead and looking at criteria
based changes again in 89 day period and
looking at comparisons and then from
period one to period two the density
stocking densities that we were looking
at in here in regards to total again
this was an area that could hold up to
about 6,000 cages but at the current
time they were still building so the
caging that they had there is about
2,400 then with one animal to animal
three animal for animal five animals you
can see the stocking densities here and
then the breeding cages that were
involved with those two there is a
preponderance of one animal here a lot
of these were individual transgenic
males and females with their pups
overall so that's why you're seeing a
higher incidence with that a lot of what
would you would need to look at in your
own facility is what these densities are
within your own facility that's a very
critical aspect of this overall what I'm
going to show you next is probably the
most important slide overall for this
particular set and this is the slide
that shows the differences then in terms
of the cage change interval comparison
on the
average the total average with different
stocking densities across the board we
were seeing thirteen point four days on
a fourteen day change cycle with the BB
C system you were getting then twenty
three point two nine days related to
that so almost a ten day increase there
but again if we get into the data and
really look at one animal per cage there
was a 13 day increase there with two
animals per cage realistically we're
looking at about a 12 day increase here
with 3 animals per cage we're looking at
about a 10 day increase here so again
when we got down into the four and five
animals the difficulty differences were
not that great but there still was a a
increase here and again depending on
your stocking strains of animals these
were predominantly c57 black 6 Azure
valve sees if you're dealing with other
stocks and streams that may be more
higher producers of urine and issues
that way you may see a decrease in the
for animal and five animal cage change
period here based on the dirtiness that
you want overall it may be more
effective and evaluating that and doing
that for you so that's again looking at
animal welfare with that the big thing
here is there was a 40% reduction
overall that we're talking about with
that so we're seeing a 40% reduction for
the animals in relationship to that I
wanted to do the math for you actually
that was an approximate 40 it was
actually a forty two point four seven
percent and again if we go back and look
at with five cages and do the actual
math related to that what we're looking
at in terms of the cage change savings
for the area based again upon the 5,000
cages and based again upon these
averages that we have stocking densities
and those stocking densities staying in
the same areas we would have five 57,000
834 saved cage changes so that's pretty
important number
going forward with that then in regards
to that number one of the things that I
think we need to keep in mind here is
that we could be seeing in terms of
washing an animal holding area for the
actual savings in time of 100 seconds so
a time motion study was done and this
was split between clean cage transport
and dirty cage transport and again
that's going to be quite variable in all
your facilities so it was better to do
this in not in terms of money but
actually in terms of looking at time and
at what was looked at for this hundred
seconds overall was that
the cage system here the cage system
here okay if we're looking at the amount
of seconds that we're splitting out here
is that we're at 70 6.04 for the clean
aspect in 20 3.99
for the dirty aspect so this translates
then into actually how many hours per
annual and how many days per annum as
well in relationship to those specific
areas moving forward on that and looking
at then what that would be overall
depending on if you're on an eight day
drives an eight hour per day workday or
a seven hour per day workday this could
either be 48 days or 55 days for the
dirty technician time only for the clean
technician time if you're looking at
that we're seeing that this could be at
158 days or one hundred and seventy four
point six days if it's a seven hour per
day versus Nate hour per day there's a
lot of variability with that again so
the one thing that we don't have
variability with as how many how much
substrate it would change would save and
that substrate is about eleven thousand
two hundred kilograms that substrate so
all in all there's quite a significant
savings outweigh I wanted to point out
that this was done in collaboration
there were other groups that were
working on this as well what I've shown
you is the most recent data but bioserve
is a group we've just looked at we'll
look at another group here shortly these
are all European groups here whereas
this here tends to be the u.s.
contingency right now so there is active
group working overall with this and
perspectives from leadership in regards
to the Netherlands and Linden University
just wanted to show you that there was
an experimental design for a very
similar beta study in regards to
changing not using as many cages only 60
cages and then doing this with ten
animals with the different stocking
densities and then getting the results
in relationship much similar to what was
done in previous study phase one phase
two and phase three and getting ideas of
the differences in regards to the BBC
directed cage change out in cage cage
change algorithm as a final phase three
and the bottom line and this was if
there was good validation correlation
with what we had just a scene from
bioserve so this is an others that I've
talked to have gone up as high as 65
percent and others have gone as low as
thirty percent on this so again there's
there's variability here and I think the
bottom line with all this is there's a
significant reduction of cage changes
per unit of time while maintaining
acceptable cage conditions through use
of digitalization systems for the caging
overall the translation if they if with
the particular netherlands study that
was done was looking at a twelve
thousand cage change then if that was
being done and this gives you some data
and relationship to that as an estimator
that savings overall not realistic the
other one from
see was actually realistic because of
the amount of cages that were being used
in those areas and how many will be put
through there so again it goes back to
your stocking densities though moving
that way the other thing that this
allows is we go from this calendar
system if we've been indoctrinated in
for many years and been non flexible
with to a system that now allows us to
have quite a lot of variation and
ability and latitude in how we use our
resources I should point out as well
that the system is careful not to go
ahead and save up a three thousand cage
change for one day they will anticipate
if there are a bunch of dirty cages
coming forward so again this is the
learning phase that we're talking about
and machine learning within the system
itself and when that system starts
seeing that it pushes some K changes
forward it also recognizes weekends and
holidays and allows them to work around
those if you will and what I mean by
that is moving K change forward or going
ahead and anticipating how dirty those
cages might get and still being
acceptable though but keeping them at a
level where they can go ahead and move
around that so the system is very
sophisticated in regards to this but it
is user friendly and has a great
interface as well in the ability to do
that so going forward and again kind of
concluding with this talking about this
cage change washed initiation schedule
and going through all of the aspects of
that or a Internet of the vivarium and a
smart building we would need to then go
ahead and tie that into the cage wash
and and evaluate how many dirty units
are coming down have resources available
for that and then allocate those
resources and be able to move them
through that by and with some of our
software systems in terms of management
we're actually able to start to do some
of this already so it's a very exciting
time for us I think in regards to all of
this so what I did want to mention is
that
we talked only about the betting
conditions so far and a little bit about
animal activity but there are several
other things that can be done with these
systems with these digital systems as
well and I think that's important we
also talked a little bit about the food
and water levels but there are many
things that can be done with ease and I
think that they can be add-ons and
expansion as well so it's an exciting
time for us in the lab animal community
I wanted to get into a little bit more
on the activity and to show you a little
bit of how that works so again we said
these algorithms can be run at the same
time that we're seeing with the cage
change or with the cage conditions and
if we look at the drop of that signal
and how many signals were getting from
just one of the sensors that's 240
samples in one minute we're looking
about 3,000 samples per minute and in
relationship to the board and that
translates out to many signals per hour
but I want to compare this to the video
systems and have you recognize that with
the video systems the amount of data
that's actually being pushed forward
there is much higher than what we are
seeing here with some of the with the
EMS system overall so there is a lot of
data you need to understand how you're
going to manage that data and it's
really important as to who has access to
the data
the investigators need access to the
data obviously management managers in
the facility will need access to the
data and how often do they need that
data and then how long are you going to
store the data I think as we move
forward with these mega data sets and
other large data compilations that we're
seeing storage of data is becoming more
costly actually then some of the and
often using some of the systems to
analyze the data itself and to move
forward with it so this is something
that should be looked at from the
administrative level regarding this
overall getting back into the heat map
and talking about activity levels we can
see here that on a heat map and that
just shows where the red is
is it's more active we're having a cage
gene or monitoring a cage here over a 10
day period and during that in that 10
day period on day 3 there was a cage
change done and what is readily apparent
from this heat map is that you can see
related to that cage change that there's
a lot more activity up here than there
would be in other days that would not
have as much activity there so anytime
you change a cage the bottom line of
this is if you're creating a lot more of
stress on those animals and there's a
lot more activity for either fair
hormone marking or marking the cage on
those animals a lot more increased
activity and disruptions where normally
in the night time there's high activity
and that's where you see most the
activity and actually it's kind of a
biphasic early on and then later in the
night you see that occurring right
before the morning time period and kind
of a feeding area here as well and it's
interesting to be able to see that
notice that in different strains that we
do have so the one thing that we wanted
to look at is what happens if you do
diet restriction what god what are the
activity changes that might be occurring
with diet restriction this was done
through the the consortium that I showed
you earlier and this was done up in
Sweden at the Karolinska Institute and
what we were actually seeing is where
when I showed you the first heat map he
saw that during the night there was very
high activity during the day very low
what we're seeing is a reversal of that
in the diet restriction animals now
these animals were fed at 10:00 I think
it was 10 o'clock
overall so that really caused some
issues in regards to box R they were fed
anew so these animals were fed at noon
so what you're seeing is where these
animals are hungry they want to get fed
so instead of waiting into the night
period to eat they immediately went to
the theater and is this affecting them
their circadian rhythm and some of the
issues it might be behaviorally
important for the investigator and some
of the areas that they're looking at so
really we need to be
instead of this and be very careful of
how we're feeding animals and diet
restriction and when we feed them
related to their normal activity period
and how that occurs one of the other
things that I wanted to show here was a
breeding algorithm and show how this can
be used to help predict when parturition
might occur in caging and what we see
are a couple different things here with
this is where the animals are starting
to congregate in one corner of the cage
predominantly and and this is an
apparent system we are working on pyram
as well and getting better definition
with the harab systems and how those are
working but what we are seeing is within
these systems is where they're going
into the corners of the cage and staying
in that corner and that's a high
predictability of when that happens but
even a better predictability of this in
more effective is the average velocity
in the animal how fast it's moving and
as it decreases its velocity there's a
higher predictability for the per
tradition as well so both of those
together going in the corner and
decrease velocity gives a high very high
confidence rate or when parturition will
occur in these animals another thing
that can be used for the activity
monitoring is phenotyping a lot of
places are looking at many different
transgenics and what we are seeing is a
huge increase with CRISPR grass 9 and
transgenic creation so as a result of
that going through and doing the
phenotyping on these is very important
this is particular one is with the ALS
syndrome and looking at sod1 mice which
are a model for ALS and being able to
predict women these animals are
developing this disease process because
the pathology often preclude Zoar is
earlier much earlier on than the
clinical signs and it's important for
the research to be able to find the
pathology first and then to address that
pathology so by looking at animal
movement we can actually understand when
the pathology is starting and do this at
a much earlier time period as being
shown here
with the one animal s OD animal - s OD
animals and then again in a different
graphical depiction here showing
affected animals being able to be seen
much earlier than when the control
animals are there as well so it's a
definite advantage for the investigators
who are active in this area and who need
to have earlier clinical symptom ology
are actually pathology identified and
not just rely on the clinical symptom
ology because often by the time they're
showing the clinical signs it's too late
for some of the things that they want to
intervene with my last pen I'm part of
this presentation will just be talking
about stroke and evaluating some of the
stroke models here are using this system
to help evaluate a stroke model overall
and being able to see what how that can
be used for intervention in the stroke
model and evaluation so this was doing a
time 30-minute unilateral clue you in
the middle cerebral artery and the
design of the experiment was doing some
behavioral testing at a time baseline
then doing the actual stroke and then
going ahead and giving different diets
in relationship to stroke therapies
overall and how effective these diets
might be these are antioxidant diets and
based on fish oils omega-3 is actually
heavy in that so this is some of the
things that were being looked at with
this some of the behavior tests that
we're done were open field Pro - rod
grip strength pull test and novel object
recognitions so these are the control
diet was your basic diet that way and
then the four stand diet was the
antioxidant omega-3 rich fish oil diet
that way in an open field activity when
that was done and by the postdocs here
velocity and distance walked after
stroke there was no dietary fact noticed
with this and then 14 days post stroke
really again no dietary effect was
noticed
this and the pole testing on this Mouse
in the forest and turned a little bit
faster and they had improved motor
coordination and actually with the
cerebral blood flow what we were seeing
here is that there was a increase of
cerebral blood flow with the force and
at 8:35 that right hemisphere right
hippocampus at 8:35 with the animals
that way so the question came up well
what about the open field results and
could there be a better way to look at
this maybe with the BBC and so there was
a little bit of things that they wanted
to look at in terms of the distance the
velocity and then the angulations using
the DVC system and then comparing that
somewhat to the open field overall one
of the big things that this did allow as
well is to look at where the major
activity was when the lights were off as
we would have assumed there was a lot
more activity overall on the in the
animals across the board both in
controls and in the dietary animals that
way activation on the boards in regards
to centers corners walls global cage
much more activity in the evening hours
again and again into the corners we seem
to see more because again these guys are
more thick tactic that way so and the
comparison if we look at lights on
lights off and in the diet and control
groups we can see that there was much
higher activity in the dietary groups in
the evenings overall activation on the
boards again showing some of the
activations with the different control
diets and intestines at the beginning
and at the end of the studies showed
that there was more activations their
distance walk displacement length
looking at it then with the open field
during the day in the DBC at night the
distance walked increased over time and
during the night for this and it's
almost a reversal of what was being seen
here with the open fields this is pretty
critical for their study and for some of
the things that were looking at
and activities in the corners we saw
more activity on the force and diet and
corners especially at the night time so
again looking in the evening rather than
the daytime and evaluating these animals
in their proper time period of when
their behavior is the most active or
their normal behavior we might say is
occurring rather than in daytime when
it's abnormal or their nighttime
behavior where they're resting usually
so really critical for the study and
increased at night again due to the diet
that way one of the questions that came
up by the investigator was is there more
stress with some of these different
testing modalities that they're doing
the different behavior testings so one
of the things I looked at was how much
activity there is post testing and then
correlating that to a possibility of it
being a stressful event if there's
higher activity because of the fact of
what we had seen actually with cage
changes and others where animals are
aroused and they're more active and
they're a little more stress in
relationship to what they're doing that
way and may take them longer to self
down post the studies that way so in
doing this the stress activity levels
four hours before or four hours before
ever after every test no particular
stress returned to the homepage after
testing with the open field or that the
poll testing but the grip test was
somewhat stressful what appeared because
it was a quite an increase there was a
slight increase in the neuroimaging and
rota rod but again the grip test was
most apparent as being most creating
most and then the advantage of the DVC
over open field is that we are looking
at we're monitoring the subtle subtle
changes in activity walking patterns
location the animals can't be detected
in current experimental settings with
the open field
last week almost more active faster
longer distance in first week monitoring
activity before and after test shows a
significant increase movement during
first four hours after the grip test
compared to four hours before the test
so is it stressful you know again that's
a consumption there it's not a proven
entity but it would seem that way
animals and control diet set more in
corners they're less active and have
preference for left turns and first week
compared to the forest diet so again
this is a valuable data for the
investigator or looking at that type of
dietary replacement and correction for
stroke and also for people who have
stroke so and what we can say in our
summary slide here is that cage
automation is evolving it is at the
Internet of the vivarium I would like to
say I think we're starting toward that
we're nowhere near it
at a point now but you know we're doing
baby steps and one of the first baby
steps is this cage technology looking
toward that and we buy in that direction
by very market texture and design
components you'd be able to incorporate
and support these systems in regards to
the new facility designs and
retrofitting and being able to support
some of the high databases that we need
and then how are you going to store that
data and where are you going to store
that data the advantage of this is do a
room usage both holding study allows
rapid study scalability and flexibility
in regards to using some of the
digitalized caging for study results at
this point in time I'd like to thank you
for this long presentation I didn't mean
it to be this long if it's got that way
and then I think any questions that we
might have at this time
thank you John Hasson out for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask the question drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started our
first question is what safety testing
has been done
continuous homepage systems the with a
lot of the video systems and the
metabolic systems the infrared beam
brake systems vibration systems I'm not
aware of much safety testing that's been
done or evaluation of those with the EMF
I'm more familiar with that and I can
say that the company that has been
working with this has done a year-long
study with their with the EMF at a level
that would be used during study looking
both clinical pathology and pathology
this was presented in the Piazza meeting
symposium that was held in Brussels and
the results of that showed that there
were no significant pathological changes
either clinical pathology or gross per
installation pathology related to its
system to use it's also and the EMF
itself has had a lot of discussion in
regards to phone technology although
that is a much higher Hertz level than
what we're seeing with this technology
and again there's been extensive testing
and other things have been done with
that and as we all know we all are
relatively easily using our own stone
and have that technology in hand most
about time of the day so I can barely
safely say here that I think it's a very
safe system and we have not seen issues
with this all hopefully that answered
the question thank you
our next question is what is the ROI
that you would see with the DVC
component for just doing the cage
changes good question but still there's
a lot of variables here and one of the
things that we really need to think
about it is each institution and the
stocking densities at each institution
as I showed you in the prison
if you have a lot of ones twos or threes
your ROI is going to be really good
because it's going to be pretty quick in
terms of how high your change out
intervals are going to be increased
related to that fours and fives stocking
density you may not have as great a
return of investment on those over time
but I think you know I think the
question was just for the cage change
out so that's you know one part of it
the other thing that I showed in the
presentation that I didn't elaborate on
was that was just a technician time that
I was showing a good savings on there in
terms of the days what I did not show
was utility savings a wear and tear on
the caging the amount of caging backup
that you need in terms of stock of stock
or cage change outs and then also wear
and tear on changing equipment the cage
washers themselves are related to how
much caging and putting through so
that's just one area that you're saving
with this so I think there probably are
further talks it could be done on that
and really evaluate that as well in
relationship to that so it's hard to say
there is no one set number you can come
up with but it would be more of a
formula looking at first the stocking
densities and kind of getting that in
hand and then going ahead and putting in
the other variables there are you
working on a seven hour work day or
eight hour work day with you know what's
the actual real realistic work day that
you have there those are all factors as
well thank you
our next question is how do you engage
the care staff towards these systems and
encourage their acceptance yes I
remember when the first time this staffs
were starting to see the robotic washers
coming through in
and that you know walking through ALS
the last shows with staff and getting
their feedback from that and quite a lot
of worry on their part in terms of being
replaced I think you know one of the
things that we have to encourage
everyone about is that are we doing
everything that we should be doing
currently in the facilities in
relationship to the time allocations
that we have and then how thoroughly can
we really look at a cage in relationship
to you know all the cages in the
facility and really evaluate those over
time I think that's an important concept
for the staff to have as well and that
we're awed menteng them not replacing
them this is an augmentation this should
help them in what they're doing and that
this would be benefiting welfare as well
for the animals in relationship to when
we can find if these cages that are
either dirty or flooded or other
problems that way and react to them in a
timely fashion a lot of these the
systems in Europe Eze are running out
and some of these in the US are running
in the evenings when no one's in the
facility and the animals are at their
high activity time periods and then
what's happening is you know they're
they're doing their algorithms early in
the morning and what is a lot of what is
happening then is and that's before the
staff comes in and then they're creating
a you know the reports right before the
staff comes in so the staff has the
ability to address these issues that are
filing through the systems right off
first thing in the morning early on and
again that can be adjusted to so that
there could be a PM shift coming in if
there were you know a rack that had
extremely valuable animals but I think
that the major thing for the engagement
of staff and encouragement of acceptance
here as I understand the question is
that the staff is not being replaced its
augmenting the welfare and the care of
the animals overall it should be you
know accept it or
as we talked about in the talk the other
good thing to do might be to take the
staff down and walk them through cage
wash and show you know okay here's you
know a hundred pages out of these
hundred cages how many of these cages
really really needed to be changed at
the calendar time when we're looking at
this and I've done that in some
facilities and it's amazing you know the
responses you get is oh my gosh what
waste we're doing here so those are
those are approaches that I you know
that couldn't possibly be used and
things that could be done I would like
to once again thank John Jerry has an
hour for his presentation
I would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018
you'll receive an email from labrys
letting you know and this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcements that your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye